what what's happening which is that
we're collectively accelerating the rate
at which we learn things in the chief
way that we learn as a species is to the
scientific method method and I wrote one
of the first histories of the scientific
method itself and my point in writing it
was that in the next 50 years the
scientific method is gonna change more
than it has the last 500 years that the
scientific method itself is evolving and
accumulating new and techniques and that
science the very method science itself
not just that stuff that science
discoveries but the process of science
is also changing which is so exciting it
is because collectively we are learning
how to learn in more ways and faster and
deeper and the consensus mechanisms are
absolutely and you know
foremost among all the changes that are
coming in the side of the method is
going to be a ice artificial
intelligences always say plural because
there are many different varieties of
them and they are going to be
instrumental in helping us because our
human minds are not general purpose
intelligence is that's a complete myth
there is no general purpose intelligence
we have very very specific weird
combinations of cognition that we're
evolved for our planet and they're gonna
they're probably insufficient to
understand dark matter and dark energy
or to you know to discover how they work
and we're gonna need to do a two step
process we're going to invent other
kinds of minds that think differently
than we do to work with us together
collectively to figure these out so so
that's sort of what's in store for it my
only point about that is there is a
collective meta learning that we're
doing but there's also the individual
assignment that we have as individuals
to never learn and that's
in my opinion much further behind in a
sense that we're not even aware of the
issues we're not aware that this is our
job that we need to learn how we learn
ourselves or to optimize our home
learning and there's no curriculum I've
seen anywhere in the world that teaches
you or me how to optimize and understand
our own learning because each of us
learn a little differently for different
things and what we want to be able to
arrive at is is to know fully well how
we would best learn a new language how
we would best learn a new physical skill
how we would best learn a new discipline
how many hours of rest we need between
this how much we have to devote to the
practice we don't know we have no idea
and this is what I think schools should
really be teaching that when you
graduate what you're graduating with is
a great a degree in self learning mm-hmm
a degree in how to optimize your own
learning so that you know yourself the
best patterns and techniques the best
way to learn all the different things
ways that need to be learned and you
know what they are and you've been
practicing you've been tested and you've
been helped by teachers to optimize your
own learning that is what high school
college should be